today's episode is brought to you by a
gray block Pizza gray block Pizza 18:11
Pico Boulevard on the way to the beach
in Los Angeles gray block get that
hitter of all long had a theory that
that they should it should be documented
on humans if you are c-section baby if
you were given birth a c-section breech
doggystyle however you were conceived as
well should be documented because I feel
like that goes in a lot of like how you
are formed for sure if you're a
missionary baby you know what are you
you know you got a lot of work to do if
your doggy style baby
oh you're talking about conception
inception so conception matters to like
how the sperm gets in there yeah so
sperm is upside down yeah if the sperm I
mean it's like if the sperm is you know
it's been a wild night if the sperm has
been like kind of a calm afternoon you
know just depends on what's I feel like
if that could it could determine who you
are a little bit absolutely
I like your c-section theory you do yeah
just because someone said like the
reason childbirth is so painful is
because you're the woman needs to go
through that to love the kid yeah and
maybe you when you get numbed up or when
you get the c-section you just don't
have that attachment I could see that
you know like what you got it you got to
go through the gauntlet
you got to suffer and then you enjoy it
yeah yeah it's like that show remember
that show that had those people with
steroids at the end of it yeah a
gladiator
yeah merican gladiators yes yeah like
what if you just won the show at the
beginning you know yeah it sucks
like I don't care yeah I like that one
where they had the tennis ball gun you
remember that was only for the rest of
it was just [ __ ] yeah it was just
like you know whatever and result is
here I'm here man what's up man nice to
meet you we ever even met no I think
I've seen you in New York I think I saw
you in New York
kind of you were hanging out maybe came
by the the village lantern yeah but I
never we never I think officially met
though I have a funny story I think you
had blood sex with my friend oh yeah
[Laughter]
there at least thank you yeah
Lyndsey was her name and you guys met at
Spring Break
this is back MTV days Oh a long time ago
yeah from Buffalo so she goes cuz I was
like oh I'm gonna you posted or I posted
I was gonna come out here and do this
and try this is so easy to be a picture
of her yes I did I I don't know I didn't
send you any picture I want to surprise
you and so I said okay boom we'll talk
about when we gonna podcast and she goes
yeah like we met at the Spring Break
thing I think you were hosting if I met
her a young break yes spring break break
and I think you guys had a wild night or
something like that maybe some butt sex
in a shower she's not totally sure she
thinks it was butt sex but it was only
ever had butt sex one time so Navy youth
yeah and this was how that's all lost my
virginity was but sex yeah bowling alley
actually Tiffany Lanes bowling alley on
highway 190 and it's still open shouts -
Tiffany lanes oh that's a plug picking
up splits out back hey and people are
throwing rocks at us while you were but
[ __ ] yeah that's fun at all can we
don't term but oh sorry I apologize yes
so boy but loving what we how do you
want there it is having sex and who
knows where we were right right I mean
it starts with the young what kids were
throwing rocks at it was very
middle-eastern yeah maybe cuz you know
who were in the wrong hole known from
that far away you know well maybe they
could've yeah but I do remember people
throwing rocks and it's hard to keep an
erection while you while people are
throwing rocks for sure and I remember
being kind of proud of myself because
you did it yeah just feeling like oh man
well so much it happened at once ya know
overcome these bully kids and I'd also
had sex you know why you were able to do
that natural birth yeah then that
c-section on somebody good for all in
that long yes
Jerome somebody crawling out of the
frickin did you get to look around
decide if you want to come out or not no
I'm the old-fashioned way you had to get
idea to come out of your mother's vagina
man I'm a real champ pushing like a G
head first what was tell me more about
Lindsey that's a nice girl she's the
coolest man she's cool as hell she said
you were cool she said one time you went
to go like visit her up in Buffalo or so
well oh wait now I think I remember this
girl blonde hair sure yes yeah yeah
great girl cool and yes it seemed like a
cool girl I said tell me a funny story
oh yeah yeah I can bring up on the
podcast and she's like well one time we
were having sex and then we were having
sex for a little while and then yeah a
little while that's right a lot of
naysayers out there we go myself up in
there and and then you came and then you
just said game over oh wow that's pretty
cool man I thought that's a great way to
come just like but you were like game
over yeah I wish I had some drawings of
it or some it sounds like it was a hoot
that's what I wish yeah tell her I said
what's up absolutely she'll watch it I
hope I did justice to the story which is
my camp yeah and I'm glad that we met
each other Lindsey seem like a nice
person and also I'm gonna say this the
first time I ever saw you I think was at
Village Lantern yes and you had
performed I'd never ever I'd never heard
of your seeing you which you know was
always a weird thing to tell another
comedian but totally good I don't mean
that in any weird way but you know I
didn't know what hardly anybody from New
York you know the only people I even
knew from New York were like Schumer
Chris Rock right um you know big Jay
oakerson cuz I'd see him out here a good
bit but I was like and I had to go next
and I was like [ __ ] no what is that guy
doing like no I do not I don't know if
everything's okay
I was asking people like how like weird
questions were coming out of me like how
long is this building been a structure
like [ __ ] that was like just [ __ ]
like survival pieces of things were
coming out of me man that's good it was
interesting man you crossed bro you
crossed and it was and I just all my
confidence had just had was suddenly on
rollerskates inside of me and it just
felt uncertain not good so but yeah so
yeah may you certainly have that effect
where you you know you just have that
power up there you know comment you
someone have you all what did you always
kind of have that whenever you started
doing stand-up what like how is that
kind of change I think that I think that
like I think I maybe had presence
obviously before jokes right you know I
think you get it's one of the other some
people have jokes first they have no
presence and then some people of
presence and they're no joke so I had
like they had presence but the jokes
just weren't there in the beginning you
know the dumb ideas you come up with and
as a young comic and then I think I
started to get some jokes and then like
for like a year I just sat down and
people thought it was like an arrogant
thing but I was just trying to not sell
the joke oh I see what you're saying
yeah cuz video but I seemed it seemed
like a machine gun kind of you know yeah
and I used to always be like that and I
can still be like that sometimes oh good
night when I get going I'm going on a
thing it's almost like on a little
roller coaster it's like this is gonna
be the ride yeah it works best if you
just kind of let me take us on it except
and we're in your world yeah in my world
exactly and but like those couple years
are like that year where I just sat and
told the joke is like I really found out
where the funny was in the jokes like I
found out how to use silence and like
build tension break it and it you know
it was also kind of humbling but it was
one of those things like it just taught
me a lot about like the art like what I
thought maybe needed energy early on
because that's what I think we
compensate with early is energy right
you can see a lot of guys East Coast and
West Coast both do it's like I'm gonna
be big
yes cuz I don't know where the punch
line is but if I'm big they see
something happening and they'll kind of
chuckle yeah and then as I got really
small I like learned where the funny was
in bits mhm
you know yeah yeah man so that's
interesting and I'm sure it probably
just gets even more more interesting
longer you do it now man it's just so
much like the more I think of this [ __ ]
like it's just bullfighting
yeah you know like for me is I just want
to get as close as I can to the bowl oh
right on
right like yeah you seem like you got
that more that risque in you
yeah just that's what excites me about
it's like like you really want to be a
stripper yes but you're just not telling
anybody I don't want to this is what I
want to do I don't want to strip my
clothes off yeah I want to strip the
audience's yeah does that make sense
that yeah so it's like I I want I want
to like attack an idea that you think
you're a hundred percent concrete on
yeah and then I want to like strip your
belief in that idea like you're a
hundred percent you believe in it you
know like the maggot hat is awful and
I'll be like what about like a viking
hat yeah and you'll go oh yes the Viking
doesn't stand for that good [ __ ] right
it's like I just want to shake I want to
shake the ground a little bit and I
think you are a Jets helmet I don't know
where are we going with that no just
like bad [ __ ] head way oh I was
talking about like you know represents
like oh yeah yeah that's yeah yeah yeah
yeah I don't think the Jets had that no
maybe Namath yeah maybe some pictures
when he was on the Jets that's true like
Vikings too and he was a Viking where do
you think he learned how to do that huh
Minnesota now Wisconsin yeah but it's
just one of those things where it's like
and I'm sure you have this as a comic as
well as just like the second you tell me
something is one way I can't accept that
like to me the world is things things
aren't black or white things are both
right right something is and isn't will
see or isn't I like Warren and or
different right you know what I mean I'm
trying to think of a bit that I heard
you talking about that I was just like
man this is [ __ ] baffling that he
says reasons on this was like a probably
a year ago year and a half ago the women
food bit mmm yeah I don't want to go
through all your bits make it weird
people often buy friend that one that
the job is about how like like gender
inequality isn't all bad used the women
from the most oppressed countries got
the best food right
I say look places with a lot of racism
got good food oppression you need a
person for content did you need
oppression to get water to boil max max
is rule like like if you look at like
iron like Ireland there's like 3 million
people from Ireland yeah I don't think
why the [ __ ] is all this great
literature poetry music like why does it
come from this one little place and it's
just because they were there was one
tiny little people for art Wow right it
was like you can't express your feelings
any other way besides singing yeah
that's it so Bono was like I I got this
like if bottle grew up in like America
it would be special to be some douchebag
with glasses yeah but Ireland it's like
final sing about it yeah I got to get it
out of that's the only way I can it's
the birth [ __ ] yeah right it's that
canal it's go through small homes a lot
of c-section artists out there now
they're artists with yeah really I mean
there's a lot of c-section artists out
here now it's like you meant like the
way they cut the belly for the baby to
come out I came out a circle yeah would
you come out of oh I came out of an
octagon put you're a c-section artists
it's a lot of art being produced by
people who are this fits here
that's piece this together oh let's cut
this person right out of here and let's
fit them in that's interesting man it's
and a lot of people have to go through
the canal yeah it's not organic it's
like the adversity introduces you to
yourself you know it's like oftentimes
like the worst thing that happens in
your career is the best thing that
happens in your career yeah please
that's why I feel well I've noticed the
worst thing has happened in your life
for me turn around to be the things that
have given me ammunition to make any
real art for myself because you have
perspective you know yeah I think I
don't know what it is I think some of
them just have to go through a time
where they feel a certain way inside of
you and then you have to get them out
you know but you might had a friend of
his had died of cancer oh really
yeah and they're gonna say AIDS honestly
no no no it's not AIDS I'm sure he's had
friends cidades yeah but um in New York
specifically not he was from Detroit and
my buddies from Atlanta but or
Jacksonville and but
he's like the cancer was a gift and I
was like why he goes because it's God
going hey wrap things up mmm like if you
and I just die you don't have wrap
things up it's like God giving you three
to five years to go live this [ __ ] right
cuz you might not have lived it if you
lived until 90 right I'll figure that
out yeah yeah and like and he's aware of
it he was this is my perspective you get
to choose your perspective on every
little thing like you've chosen the
perspective of all that [ __ ] [ __ ] I went
through yeah has made me this guy who's
able to turn ideas into comedy and have
a career on it yeah so you've found joy
in the fucked-up things you went through
that's just perspective some people do
that exact same thing and then they kill
themselves right it's interesting man
that um that's such as such a
fascinating way to look at such a great
perspective on having cancer like you
know on having something terminal it's
like that you actually get gift yeah
they look at as a gift because in the
end the own that's really the otherwise
you just it's the other way where it's
like you're just [ __ ] no one knows when
they're gonna die so they don't live
Yeah right they're not like I got to get
this done yeah a second you got a timer
it's like oh [ __ ] maybe I should go to
Greece yeah yeah maybe I should do that
snorkeling that's what they did for us
to eat this jar of Olives I've had but
[ __ ] what Andrew know we can curse we
don't say but we're not that crazy man
you know I mean will say like behold
behold okay do-do I'll say this so this
is just when I remember hearing our when
I first I was like how is this guy not
how does how do I not know about this
guy right that's when I remember hearing
about you when I saw you and they're
like oh well this thought I heard the
industry he doesn't really pick him up
because he's he has like aunt somebody
said but it's and this is just so I have
no clue this was they oh he's aunt or he
has too many jokes that are too
masculine or - he's not like so you know
it was like not supportive effeminate or
something like that
right that's what I heard did you ever
feel that or was that a real thing or is
that just something some [ __ ] told
me um I think that that was maybe the
sense and we do say [ __ ] oh yeah you
hit that [ __ ] yeah everyone needs a
powerful well I had a [ __ ] you said
been saying what you've been saying I've
evil Boogie behold boogie Umbra we're
trying to stay off from about 80 days
off pornography right now 80 yeah so me
just saying but [ __ ] has got you feeling
away I mean it's definitely got my eyes
wet a little more damp than they were
earlier this morning okay connect feel
warm
oh you really go through it yeah once
trying to stay out of that so I'm trying
to just stay in the conversation and
just you know know where I am and just
keep my feet on the ground yeah dude
that sex is gonna be amazing
well we'll see but also not being on
pornography is great something must be
getting here there's definitely more
Nass and there were before but yeah did
you ever feel that like you feel like
the industry wouldn't give you a shock
I'm like yeah this dude is a straight
killer yeah you're making your own shot
I had to but like yeah yet I've never
done stand-up on TV of audition for
everything and yeah same here
you got it yeah you know no meeting like
you understand it yeah
and it's um I mean there's a we can get
into like a couple different reasons why
that is
there is incompetence on the the people
that are like choosing folks I mean and
so like if they don't see something in
you you have to also look at that as a
compliment because they didn't see
something in burr they didn't see
something in a lot of these people they
were doing yeah like bird got his
special you know I mean but like the
fact that Sebastian hasn't had a sitcom
he gets a deal every year right here's
millions of fans but you can't make a
show around that yeah like buddy it's
not that hard like the work is done yeah
you don't have to introduce this guy
yeah he's introduced give him a kitchen
and living room
yeah it's kitchen living room where's
ray Romano's house put him in right yeah
put him in there where's who's the boss
huh
who's the new boss he says that not a
[ __ ] show ha that's the show yeah so
so what happened with me is I realized
that I feel my own special and I'll just
do it myself and I'll go sell it and I
did I did five different comedy clubs
and one
Knight and I did the the car rides taxis
in between and like I was like this is
New York yes I figured you're not gonna
pick it up because you have something
against me
so I'll increase the artistic quality
around it and like if you care about the
artist stand up you'll want to show this
experience you know and pitch it to
everybody and everybody said no
literally everybody like the networks
that I was gonna say no to said no like
that yeah humbling I mean like a
7-eleven a poor little man we don't need
you know so right Oh God see so see you
what you [ __ ] art there's got a bunch
of people's art and then went out of
business and held on to it acts yeah so
they could sell it else it whole so
basically I I go it was the lowest point
in my career I'm like am I not good it
didn't like what's going on what's
happening like yeah and I said [ __ ] it
I'm gonna put it out myself but if I'm
gonna put out myself I got to understand
comedy a little bit better I got to
understand like the what's going on and
how people watch it and I started asking
you've learned so much about comedy from
asking your non-comic friends about it
and I kept asking my not coming friends
a big you watching they stand up who you
watch in like who these names and yeah
you're not watched you know Mulaney or
all these different guys in the big I
was so funny and then they'd always say
yeah but I didn't finish it yeah
everyone said I didn't finish it and I
got ok it's too long the hours too long
I'll have enough time for the hour right
right so I go care I'm gonna do it
shorter let me do 15 I put 4 clubs
instead of 5 I cut it into 15 I put it
out on my youtube channel yeah in that
weekend I sell out a couple shows in San
Diego and I'm like that's weird I mean
I'm gonna sell out I like that's good
maybe it's maybe I have a market that I
didn't know about or something in San
Diego and I did like Columbus Ohio and I
saw them like 1600 tickets damn and yeah
I was just there man it's awesome it's
an amazing crowd your amazing Club
[ __ ] great crowd and and I figured
and I was like no this is a good club
they get people out like maybe it's some
people but like people come up to me and
are saying they watch the YouTube thing
I was like what the [ __ ] is happening so
I go oh [ __ ] maybe it's on YouTube it's
like maybe that's where people are
consuming as [ __ ] and I start I go you
know I'm gonna put a new clip out every
single week for a year yeah and I start
putting these new clips out on YouTube
and like Instagram and Twitter
and a couple of them will start to go
viral and then my YouTube guy about like
halfway in hits me up and he goes uh hey
man something kind of cool is happening
I'm like what's up and he's like like
when people watch a video they end up
watching for like two hours
Wow and I was like what that's like a
kidnapping that's like almost like
Stockholm Syndrome is dude it is and I
was like that's a Schultz effect I guess
but what I realized was was that if you
ask somebody hey can you sit here for an
hour and watch something they will say
no yes that's an absurd thing to ask
somebody I agree
but we've all been in that place where
we get locked in a wormhole being on
Instagram or phone whatever in these
digestible content me watching clips of
you yeah you know I've watched I've
watched everybody watching clips of Owen
Benjamin in the middle of a night yeah
but this like this like like there was I
remember watching a clip with you and
Chris Edie
going at each other on opium oh yeah
like that it was so funny and I'm
watching another clip I'm just lost in
this little wormhole right and and this
is what this is what content is now so I
made it digestible yeah you know it
wasn't the whole slice of the pizza it
was like a little bagel but that's what
I think about that's what I think about
cuz I'm I'm gonna tape one soon here yes
and that's exactly the thing that I've
come to come to the conclusion like even
with like de lis and Swartz and they
just did some yes um and they would
there's only a half-hour even on Netflix
so I like it people want it in a smaller
bite saying and it's almost better that
way in a sense because half hours too
long yeah not saying is not too long
it's not too long for your fans right
but if you're trying to acquire new
right right cuz that's what I was in I
was in acquisition I was like I want
people to find me so how do you find me
it's it's Costco quite sure they say
have you seen this thing about this guy
and your friend will say hey check out
this clip your friend won't say check
this whole movie right like this
whatever so just creates this place
where you share and it's like Amistad I
the boat scenes I'm in the rest of it
what I want to watch their [ __ ] email
me the [ __ ] boat see the party bags
yeah it's there it's like I basically
put this thing I put this thing together
I was like okay it's got to be short
forum specials are done and because the
goal the special was always to get an
audience that's what we wanted yeah
I never cared about us I thought I cared
about special right I really just cared
about having fans be able to perform
live I thought I want to sit calm like I
don't want to sit calm right like I want
to perform live in front of my face I
want to stand up right and everything
around stand up right so like okay how
can I can I figure this this whole thing
out and then I noticed this [ __ ] that
started to happen is like these things
that I would put out there in the world
would start growing and affecting things
you know like I did that special that
called 4:41 where I did all the clubs
then Comedy Central like rips it off and
and calls it thank you goodnight and
does the exact same thing mmm right and
then like hmm and then I looked at
Netflix and they do a series of
15-minute specials and I'm like hmm and
I'm not saying that they stole it right
but what they noticed because the way
the industry works is the industry works
like wind right it's like they're
sailboats wherever the wind is going
that's where they go that's what I say
money isn't oil that's one of the things
that I realized it was like I kept
thinking like oh see my perspective was
this industry hates me
and I think that some of that was my own
bad perspective from growing up and just
they hate you they just saw him TV and
they're like that's it right we can't do
that I promise you that's what it was no
that's not it at all
no I could do it I've been working for
so long that has nothing to do with it
so but we don't think initially not as
though maybe a long time ago but I'm
talking about now I'm talking about like
in the past like five years oh this is
different yes is okay I'm talking about
like yeah it seems like the industry
won't give me like my perspective was
always like the industry won't give me a
chance the industry won't keep writing
it's right so yeah my thing was like
they don't but then I started was they
don't even know what's good like the
people that are making these choices I
never even see at the club taste makers
are no taste yeah and so it's kind of
baffling to me but you but don't you
feel like they're done but did you feel
like you like did you feel that you feel
like these people aren't giving me a
chance yes cuz they didn't I mean like
when I got jfl new faces I had a network
deal already with MTV okay so you had
some so you had some you had some energy
going right there but not in stand-up
the stand-up industry has always been
closed those other industry
separate for whoa acting and stuff like
that that kind of stuff yeah and I
thought I wanted it but I didn't want it
right but like so I had a sitcom yeah I
was leading a sitcom on IFC was called
benders you know maybe we did a season
watch on Netflix now I like I had a Hulu
dramedy that I was on those produced by
see so and then Hulu bought it but like
there was things I did an industry I did
films unless I liked that because they
really didn't care about what was going
on the stand-up world stand-up so
isolated really
but the stand of people in the stand-up
world they all talk to each other and
they say oh this guy's got a cent on him
so I go okay I got to get around this
and my my way of getting around it was
essentially like there's a story that
I'll use like about Nescafe breaking
into Japan you know Nescafe oh yeah I
like it
so like the way they got into Japan they
asked this consulting guys like how do
we get in and then they go the
consultant guy goes uh basically you
can't get him for 15 years they're like
why the [ __ ] not they don't even know
what coffee is like it's not tea you're
trying to be tea you're not tea I have
any emotion to attach it to it means
nothing to me it look like dirty tea
really it looks like Shetty right yeah
so he goes this is what you're gonna do
here spend millions of dollars to make a
cartoon in Japan and then you're gonna
make some candies that have to do at
that cartoon mm-hmm and those candies
are gonna taste like coffee and then in
15 years when these kids grow up they're
gonna want that coffee go to Japan now
they [ __ ] love coffee
they do it is in saying I can't even
imagine a Japanese person on coffee Sun
know they're so Zen what great uh
but yes so they're like into it right
dude kind of spoils them dude in a way I
don't want Javan evil and with coffee
now you it's one of the other so you're
[ __ ] up my tourist experience in your
country yeah I want to know somebody
that I can honestly take a nap or while
they're awake and yeah everything is
gonna be cool and you're I'm gonna get
my rest yes yeah they're like the
privacy Japanese people are yeah yeah I
think you're not asking me what's going
on like a stalker
always wanted an Asian stalker a ninja
is effective their stalkers yeah they're
on your roof yeah they're quiet yeah
uh-huh the ACS American stalker [ __ ]
yes snacking in the woods on the [ __ ]
trail delight yeah crazy van so I'm
learning about that [ __ ] and I'm like oh
this is interesting so you got effect
underneath right so you just found a new
way in basically III realize I had like
change the industry right right so it's
like if I can't the seed and it grows up
into it then I can do what I want right
right so like me doing the short special
then seeing that in comedy central's
seeing that in Netflix and like even
like Ray Romano's new special I'm not
saying he stole this from me at all
right but like his new special is going
to the Comedy Cellar and well
unannounced and walking around to the
village underground that's like that's
for 401 so I did in for for one now yeah
I'm not saying they took that in any way
from me whatever things like I made that
okay to be in a special yeah right it's
like when you see that has like millions
of views then the network goes well we
don't need it to be in a big theater
yeah it's cool that it's yeah small
little thing right right it's like yeah
it's funny they almost justify like
taking artistic ideas from people as
business it's like okay we just say oh
this is a good business move now do it
like this yeah even though if another
artist did that you would be like oh
that's kind of what almost come back to
but like everything I like everything I
do like the way like did I put the clips
on the internet and these kind of stuff
like I do that for us right
like literally any idea that I've put
out there in the world that you think is
good as a comedian please take that I am
NOT in competition with any of you
they're no longer eight comedy specials
we're fighting for a year
yeah my world is on YouTube right if
your world a lot of it is on YouTube
yeah you've had immense success on
YouTube it's like more comics will start
to realize that is if they can own their
own world but now I'm trying to do is
help you own your own world and if you
have any anything I'm doing if the
blueprint is there you [ __ ] take it
and then improve it and then tell me
yeah yeah yo start doing this on your
videos it helps it ya wear a hat yeah
boom that's the trick
yeah get that hat yeah yeah it's
interesting man it's interesting not to
hold like any like I don't need industry
bro right it's it's over like but
so here's interesting what right what I
saw I mean I see that's not the industry
if you have a network right here right
that's somebody said that the other day
they're like yeah somebody said that to
me at The Comedy Store they're like you
know it's funny like is this was an
older communion he goes out of given
anything when I was young I was looking
to be on a network and now you guys have
your own networks like you don't even
realize you have your own place what was
it never do whatever you want network
was just I both yeah that's all it was
either this for some reason is this
other idea validation matrix yeah that's
we validate ourselves we validated
ourselves by an antiquated model right
right there's there's the and I'm kind
of a traditionalist in a lot of ways so
some of that stuff actually resonates
with me a lot you know like horn oh I
need this too in order to you know it's
just like it's like anything it's like
oh it gives you it gives you a certain
level of status it was just kind of what
was endogenous man what was burned into
your brain yeah I know but that's that
like that's that southern [ __ ] like that
like class [ __ ] right do you remain yeah
I could see somebody with it you know
with [ __ ] white gloves walking down
the street and you're like oh that's one
of the rich people right this part of
town and that kind of [ __ ] like we had
in New York - oh there's the Upper East
Side
you know girls and they go to the
Catholic schools and they've got all
this money it's like who gives a [ __ ]
yeah what did you always want to do
perform for sold-out crowds yeah I mean
I like making my friends laugh at the
table dude that's what I liked when I
was in terms of oh as a pro kamar I just
wanted I should maybe I shouldn't answer
that question for you what did you
always want yeah I just wanted to be
able to do the best work that I wanted
to put myself in a position to do the
best work that I could so for me a lot
of times it's just like taking care of
myself offstage so that I know that out
so then I can do what I'm you know what
I'm able to do are you taking care of
upstairs yeah now I'm doing a better job
of it yeah so now I do a better job at
anchor but all the staging is better on
stage man and you feel good about what
you're doing on stage yeah and now I
feel bad I mean it looking mala and our
you know Hollywood I mean you know with
the election all that it was like
everybody from the place that I'm from
is like dumb they're an idiot they're
all races through all this and that was
so [ __ ] that kind of [ __ ] made me so
angry good that that made me want to be
like leaning into it yeah well now I
have to also
because some people will be like oh you
sell it by working with Hollywood it's
like well I want you also have to
recognize these people don't know any
better you know even though these people
act like they're the smartest people
they all went to these fancy schools and
they got in there for [ __ ] you know a
lot of like um nepotism and that kind of
stuff and they all act like they have
struggled so much but they've really had
a lot of help along the way that they
don't know any better they're trying to
survive right everybody's trying to
survive and so you have to so that so I
can't be like it doesn't help me anymore
anyway also to be like [ __ ] you this way
it helps me more to be like hey look at
this you know you want to say that
somebody can't come from where I'm from
and try their best and try not to be
racist and try not to be this way but be
understanding of what's going on try to
be anyway at least be you know
consciously making an effort then you're
[ __ ] wrong because I wouldn't be
alive if that's right now I can tell
about how diverse your stuff is like
yeah we got a young white guy in he
young my guy in a middle-aged white
premature baby so who knows what color
he would have been if you were to win
all my good point
did you know pigment there you go he
could be the twink - so we got a twink
and who knows the last six days but when
I you know when I looked at you I'll be
honest with you when I saw cuz what
happens is when somebody starts to
bubble and because we have the internet
now it's a free market it's not like who
execs want to bubble right it's who the
world wants to bubble who the ecosystem
asks for and I knew you were starting to
bubble because a girl sent me a clip of
yours or asked me about you and then
people would mention me with you they
would say [ __ ] like they'd be like bro
you ain't deal one of my new favorite
calm and something like that and I bet
okay so his kids bubbling let me let me
check on her stuff and there was some
bit that you did I forget it maybe was a
white privilege bit or something like
that that was online and I was like oh
he's got to lean into this because
everybody that's from where you're from
is looking for somebody to represent
them because nobody is yeah especially
in this world there are people
representing them in their world right
but who's representing them in this
world like America right now is waiting
for the likable how do I call it like
hick like not hick but like what's the
term for like southern dude like the
[ __ ] you know I mean I say I can throw
us off rural as well consider me
whatever but like throw myself redneck
I'm not that [ __ ] you know like we
didn't have any of that stuff you know
like just from a rural place and I'm
white and what it's basically waiting
for it because the majority of America
is that right we get this because we
tore these people that stay in their
offices in New York and LA don't
understand it but how do they act like
they understand it so don't even feel
right like that doesn't matter once you
realize that you don't need them right
you I think I realize that it just makes
me sad that they don't it won't because
it's falling apart
dude like deal we're talking about in
three years everything's done yeah like
when I mean everything I mean all these
networks did are saying no to you won't
be in the building they're in in three
years right so even if you gave them
content it's gone and three it like
everything you're building should be
here is there anything you can't do
yourself no what show do you do mean it
stressed out but he also has own
personal issues yeah so you got to get
through that okay yeah he doesn't need
blood young so we can always tap in him
for a pint gang you know yeah that's a
little [ __ ] twink boy that's way you
know but he's in a [ __ ] new movie
coming out and he [ __ ] does our
booking bro and he's beautiful
yeah so he's really say yeah we got a
good we got a good crew and
we're about to start a production arm
and go do a co Pro with a comedy store
on a new project see argue and you're
doing this yeah you don't need anything
else
the only tricky thing right now is how
we get advertising dollars right from TV
to the place where people are actually
watching which is us yeah it doesn't
seem fair that they get big advertising
dollars and we get right you know non
big that's just because those ad execs
that are cutting those deals are 50
right once they become 30 which will be
very soon because 50 retires once they
become 30 and 35 50
so overdoses hopefully so well not
hopefully we hope that everybody finds
you know a new experience and a more
comfortable way of life but sometimes
that's how long as they don't yeah point
is then it's [ __ ] it's coming all down
yeah it really is it's as simple as that
because right now this is good to hear
man cuz some of this is stuff where I
question myself what do you want what do
you want huh what do you want I don't
know dude I don't have breakfast I
wanted um but overall I don't know what
do you want content-wise what do I want
to do I want to start a kids channel you
know do some kids stuff you really yep
so I think we'll do that this year what
else what do you need to do for that
content-wise nothing we're gonna shoot a
special in about six weeks at the Comedy
Store those dates yet where you gonna go
with it
no I'm gonna put some of the clips on
YouTube have to yep and some Instagram
and then it will be available for sale
as a larger chunk to an outlet if they
want it why sell it you know but if I
can use some of the clips on YouTube and
the ones that I want to use then I think
that's that's good if it's a place that
would bring in new viewers to me yes
it's not just me about bringing my
viewers or you know people that are part
of our group here to them yes and
outside of that we want to do like I
want to have a halfway house one day
that's that hell that is funded by
stand-up comedy so then it's like people
it's actually to me the 51% house it's
halfway and it'll just a touch more and
um and it's for people that need help
you know and it's gonna be fun to buy
the jokes you know so it's gonna be you
know it's gonna be good man cuz because
you know cuz a lot of people are [ __ ]
sick out there yeah a lot of people that
are [ __ ] up and you felt that way yeah
it just and it's like yeah yeah I like
I'll be okay you know have enough to eat
and a place to live and it's gonna be
but you want to help them yeah it's like
imagine if you know there were direct
places like even in your community one
day you know you never know how big it
could get maybe if 30 houses around the
country or people are getting help yeah
and you're just [ __ ] driving around
making stories about how coked up you
were in a [ __ ] someone's house if
that's funding at all you know it's like
this perfect circle yeah so that would
be super cool yeah I don't just so much
where you can't do it I mean yeah that's
that's beautiful you know my fear comes
from then sometimes I
think that you're just you're caught in
this this Hollywood vacuum which you're
right which makes people think that you
can't create anything without some guy
saying okay create it but you're also
part of this system that's breaking that
down right like like like I was saying I
was just saying to the guys on the
fighter kid it's like Vernon and Byron
him Byron you can't like you can't
compete with what we're doing like you
know like Netflix is they spend a
hundred million dollars on a movie right
that distracts you for two hours right
YouTube spends zero million dollars on
this podcast that distracts you for two
hours yeah you can't win that battle
Netflix YouTube one they're just waiting
to drown Netflix they're waiting for
Netflix is just keep on piling up debt
and then it's over what I'm saying is
you're already in the ground floor of
the future right so everything you do
content wise can be done right here it's
that's already over and then when you
start making monetizing and you start
making some money you can do it you're
just in a good position and the reason
why people [ __ ] with you is because you
don't want to take your natural
inclination is to give and that's a
leadership quality that not a lot of
people have like I think that's why I
needed to go through that experience in
my career where like nobody wanted
anything from me is because I needed to
be stripped to nothing before I could
lead I I needed to feel zero and get
comfortable in zero so that if I went
back its I own I been there yeah it's
like Y like it's like you ever talked to
like like rappers or athletes that went
broke they're like I don't care I've
broken my whole life like I'm comfy do
you think Blanc Euler better being broke
than white people
I think broke people are better at being
broke yeah it's just sit like if you
know anybody that's broke
they still got [ __ ] yeah sorry I know
you don't use these words we can use
[ __ ] okay no he's at a ton okay
they still got post show me any I mean I
got rolling I got you okay hey still got
friends yeah they still got jokes
oh do being poor was fun do we used to
burn everything in the [ __ ] ditch
but is there anyone can do that that's a
fire if you don't that's gross yelling
you're poor nobody [ __ ] it comes true
used to call the cops all the time they
would never come do they come a month
later yeah dude be in port in a lot of
ways is better because you got hope yeah
somewhere to go where to go
right it's a yell one day we're gonna be
rich and we're just gonna have our own
ditch yeah in our backyard we can just
burn on [ __ ] we more have a shelving
unit yeah dude I remember what a [ __ ]
shelving unit in my [ __ ] room like
together the [ __ ] did you get that no we
didn't get it but now I had way yeah but
I remember dude somebody from the
[ __ ] somebody would drive by and
throw dead animal some veterinarian who
was saving money on corners yeah throw
dead animals in at a ditch so we'd be
out there throwing [ __ ] calf
vertebraes at each other and [ __ ] fun
and playing football with like a
Cossacks of some kind of damn yeah
animal if you're rich PETA comes for you
yeah you're rich that's a [ __ ] crime
sucks
that's Forensic Files II that's American
greed dude it really is yeah is every
serial killer do he kills the [ __ ]
animals Yeah right that's that you're
describing the behavior when you're poor
it's just fun and here ya go deep dude I
got a sternum but yeah you're right man
there was definitely some value to there
was definitely there was definitely a
ton of what are you gonna take away from
me that's the thing it was like I need
to go to zero because then I would have
no fear right yeah if I was at six I
could go down to zero so I'd be a [ __ ]
you had me stuttering my Peas because I
feel like you're afraid of the the bad
words but okay right now so if I was at
six I'd be a [ __ ] cuz I [ __ ] I could go
down to zero but I went down to zero and
I got comfy at it and now I'm at a place
where I'm prepared to do whatever yeah I
can't take anything for me yeah I like
that man I guess there's I guess for me
off y'all I still feel some fear like
that though that they will find a way
that this hypothetical they will find
what do you know take a look you're
worried about having future [ __ ] taken
away right you're like what if I lose
out on this opportunity to do this and
what if I don't get this Netflix special
or what if I don't get this Comedy
Central thing that's at the other um no
I'm kind of okay like I got a pile of
wood coming since right now it's
actually based on the podcast so it's
like it really fits in exactly like what
my
five vibe is and our goals and and stuff
so that feels great
you know but if it doesn't happen I
still feel okay say you know Oh icing
dude and that is totally different like
like it's almost like you know it used
to be out wet you know I'd be so [ __ ]
nervous months would just go away yet
because I didn't have anything else but
now it's like it you know in two years
I'd love to make a movie and put you
know my friends in it and work together
and like have you know neat ideas I want
to make like a first fit way you know
you ever see this way yeah I want to
make like a movie like that see you know
or uh should get involved with those
guys do you know David do you know uh
you know David Gordon Green if you heard
he like directs a lot of [ __ ] did uh did
Danny does Danny McBride yeah but yeah
you should have made one time yeah but
yeah I think maybe after like this year
maybe we'll try to start doing something
that'd love to maybe get one of these
you know do a co-production kind of
thing first just even get in that world
surely because also it's interesting
having to think like a business person
and then also still have time to do the
comedy you know yeah you run thin but
it's like I think you find out I think
you find out what truly makes you happy
when you have nothing and when you have
everything yeah right it's like every
rich person is like money won't make you
happy every poor person's like once I
get rich I'll be happy yeah right so
it's like once you're rich you at least
have the perspective we're not rich but
once you get enough money where it
doesn't make a difference if you have
more yeah you have the perspective to go
oh chasing this money ain't gonna give
me happiness but you know what really
made me happy man when I was working on
them jokes you know I should just work
on them jokes yeah right there's this
one moment in one of my jokes and that's
like the thing that gives me the most
happiness it's like it's kind of like I
go the whole set just for this one like
two or three second part and it's like
oh that's okay tell me where is it weird
right now it's just like this little
kind of act out at the end of like my
mom want a perm one time when I was
growing up on the radio and it's just
like this one moment when I tell part of
that story that makes me it's like I
just feel like a different person for a
second you yeah it's like a yeah it's
just like I disappear it's like yeah I
don't know it just feels like a
different I gonna live in a different
world
a couple seconds and it's cool yeah you
know it's like that's the cake and if
they laugh yeah that's icing dude like
yeah I got to a place where like I'm
just creating the things I want to
create like I want you to come on the
inside joke show right like yeah I just
and we'll do it again maybe with with a
couple weeks in a couple months but like
it was just like I fell in love with
creating like I had a conversation with
my buddy Sipho sounds and he oh yeah I
love him bro he influenced hip-hop so
much without I didn't even I knew enough
that I wanted to like show other people
but like he discovered Rihanna Rick Ross
like Sean Paul like like all these
different things like even though you
know that airhorn sound oh that's him
dude he gave you that pain he bothered
you with that like but the point was
like I did the podcast right yeah it's
actually a dancehall thing but he loved
loved dancehall music supported a pop
but like I did the podcast and I just
had so much fun doing it I felt so proud
of doing it nobody even listened yeah
and I sat there for a moment and I was
like oh oh this is this is the goal yeah
it's not waiting to see how many listens
I got in all the comments and all like
it was like no I'm already happy if you
guys [ __ ] with it - that's dope that's
cool this past weekend is brought to you
by Skillshare Skillshare it's an online
learning community for creators with
more than 25,000 classes in design
business and more you'll discover many
ways to fuel your curiosity creativity
and career you can take classes in
whatever you want you want to make
something you want to do painting you
want to do you know archery but not yet
maybe I mean you can maybe see some
stuff on it but all types of stuff
social media marketing mobile
photography creative writing even
illustration whether you're looking to
discover a new passion start a side
hustle or gain new professional skills
skills share is there to keep you
learning thriving and reaching those new
year goals join the millions of students
already learning on Skillshare today
with a special offer just for our
listeners get 2 months of Skillshare for
that's right skills share a place to
offer that offers countless classes you
don't need to go back to college for
this big degree you can learn it now
skill share is offering this past
weekend listeners two months of a
limited access to over 25,000 courses
for free
to sign up go to Skillshare dot-com
slash Theo von
again go to skills share dot-com slash
Theo von to start your two months now
that Skillshare dot-com slash Theo von
thank you for supporting this past
weekend this past weekend is brought to
you by Ridge wallet now a lot of time
you see somebody and they don't know
what the [ __ ] is going on with them and
then suddenly they do and that person
probably is someone who bought a reg
wallet a wallet is something you put in
the back of your pocket whoa where is it
who knows somebody might have stole it
or maybe there's a leak up you know in
the ceiling and it dripped into your
pocket and back pocket and ruined
everything there goes all your [ __ ] well
Ridge wallet is that front pocket carry
you're not carrying around all these
extra photos and you know different
recipes or whatever you got folded up in
there something special you know for
that exotic meatloaf now you can just do
what you need that front pocket carry
keep all your items handy go to Ridge
wallet calm and use code Theo at
checkout for 10% off that's code Theo
for 10% off at Ridge wallet dot-com and
let's get to the episode what do you
have now like as far as support go so
but do you have an agent stuff like that
you like you worry you have to monitor
five your manager yeah I don't have a
manager now either you don't need a
babysitter but we need our producers
right right like we need I don't know if
that's your role but like I knew I had a
guy who does all my video Nick very
questionable role but also that's done a
great job in helping me you know Billy
what's going on yeah especially for a
premature very so I'm saying dude just
do my best every day we don't have it
post mature babies he could have gone
post if you wanted to I think he came
out early cuz he was curious go in post
that's [ __ ] we had a look
that like 10 months 11 do comes out with
dreadful hair yeah black dudes come out
late I could imagine that like damn he's
supposed to be a wiz know like two other
black dude so it's like like guys like
you and I that want to create content
yeah and already have the ideas what we
want to create and already have the
executions we just need executors I just
need yeah I guess I've seen a more to
start work with more executors I don't
need you to [ __ ] set up a meeting
with a company I don't want to sell
something to ya I want to put all my
[ __ ] on my network so I need somebody
who's a producer that can go hey I want
to do this show here it's a charity show
we're gonna give all the money to 51% of
the halfway house whatever it is can you
set it up so I don't gotta be on all
these emails
hmm so but do you get any flack from
people in the industry like like trying
to like instill that you're doing
something wrong or anything like that
you know I'm like I don't even all I
know is that I I just keep my foot on
their neck and I just make sure that
they're copying what I'm doing right
like everything or at least I'm
influencing I'm underneath them right
all right Nescafe so like even with the
inside jokes show that I wanted you to
be about it's like that's they won't get
humbly mention it again inside joke yeah
also your podcast
no no that's not about Paco it's not
it's always with Neil and uh they did
the episode yet do it everyone it's
basically I give for comics I'll bring a
joke this is [ __ ] up like offensive
provide the crowd right and and I just
we just workshop it now I just love
talking to comics about jokes it's like
a joy for me I just think it's it's like
we get comments talking about like
topical topical [ __ ] all the time but
like and we kind of care but our jokes
we care about right cuz for those two
seconds you're like in a different world
right you love the bit yeah it's fun so
it's like but that's so that's me just
having fun with it but the the Nescafe
[ __ ] like the underneath thing is like I
see the culture where you can get
cancelled for a joke so it's like I need
to change that I need people to realize
that this is a puzzle for us a joke
right and that we it's a bullfight it's
like we're in there and we're aware that
it's danger
we're aware that it's tricky right
trying to hurt your feelings we actually
want more than anything to make you
laugh like so much and if I get
underneath them and they become fans of
the creation of the bit then they'll be
in the audience and they'll see you do a
bit and maybe it's a little bit
offensive be like oh I see where he's
going with it yeah
oh maybe when this changes but the only
way I can change the ecosystem is if I
get underneath yeah so that's what all
the projects are about like even with
the new and this is not a plug I swear
to god no plug it's ok I know it's not
but like with the new special that I'm
dropping is like for me it's like I like
doing this type of comedy I like doing
economy where it's you know edgy and
risky I'm touching on topics you're not
supposed to it's like I I know that no
network would allow these bits to be on
the network because they'd be worried
about the backlash via the industry is
almost they've almost cornered
themselves into a place where they can't
even function correct absolutely so I
know in order but doesn't neither do it
I gotta put it out yeah and then that
will shift the wind so once I put it out
the wind will go in that direction and
then all of a sudden the network's
have their sails up a little bit ok I
guess we're sailing edgy right you know
that's that's the that's my thinking
right cuz yeah cuz that and that's what
I mean my money is a little then the
money will come over that direction
because your money's just gonna go
whatever direction if you're like for so
long I had this different concept like
oh the money just hates me like it
doesn't want to come my way but the
truth is the money just goes whatever
way the the current is going yes there's
no egos in business you think there is
though and then and then there really
really isn't and the tricky thing about
stand-up is and why it's so [ __ ] up is
it doesn't make any money there's no
money for the networks in stand-up so
they know that right so since they don't
make any money out of stand-up it's not
a free market well because there's no
advertisers attached like in the
specials it's nobody watches and nobody
watches the specials it's something that
you can only do once right I mean it's
its guacamole it's like the second you
give someone a joke yeah it starts to go
stale like Chinese food
it's Chinese open from the gas station
do you ever get milk from gas station no
but I got boiled eggs
oh yeah it'd equate any four hours
that's it done dude awful bad the next
horrible it's so bad so it's like boom
there's a situation where like oh well
we don't really care like I'm just gonna
if I'm Comedy Central they've said this
to my face they're like we just give
people specials that we think we can do
a TV show with or they can be a
correspondent like it's just an
introduction to our audience yeah and I
say well do you think maybe that's why
people are watching yeah that's right
it's like yeah well they just became
this real political I like everybody
became this because they got fat oh yeah
cuz the market was ma'am there was only
ten channels we watched on TV NBC Fox
MTV vh1 was probably too old for us when
we were kids like maybe Rock a Love oh
that's later I'm talking about we were
kids
oh yeah I don't yet we didn't have it
right thanks so it's like Elton John
might have been on earth it was like all
right having an amble is like closeted
gay it was closeted that's what the h-1
really really was there yeah that really
was classics yeah classic man we got
some questions that came in from some
listeners so let's get into some of
those so boys love you both Gang Gang
okay question for you she'll see what
are the main differences between the LA
comedy scene and a New York comedy scene
from your experience I love you both get
it okay
Ellie's killing it you think without a
doubt without a doubt you guys are
killing it you guys are propping up the
scene instead of the same propping you
up New York the scene is propped up by
the seller and it's because you guys
have congealed under this empowering
like kind of freedom that you've all
gotten through your podcasts and this
kind of digital content Rogen's really
spearheaded it but this has almost
become the alt scene yeah in a weird way
to become it's like you're the Alt alt
because you guys are more traditional in
your standup yeah but you are
untraditional in the way that you're
getting your fans and that kind of stuff
so it's like but the fact that you've
brought back to life the Comedy Store
that place was dead I mean I went there
a few years back and it was [ __ ]
depressed oh it's been yeah and now it's
got life man
so it's like
when I look at the LA scene I see the
Rat Pack right when I see you daliyah
you know Brendon and Brian I want to see
you guys all [ __ ] with each other I
see you guys go on Rogan it's all the
same shows and everybody's like
everybody's yeah it's almost like Marvel
or something son it is is Justice League
or some [ __ ] yeah it's like The Avengers
so Bobby Lee all the guys are ideas I
don't know I don't know them as well but
of course I know of them but when I see
everybody you guys have created a almost
celebrity status and I really call it
the Rat Pack oh it within the comedy
community here and you have ushered in
the next generation of comics in LA if
you go who's in New York comic all the
people that maybe not you but the
average person listening thinks of are
50 right or older other Vaiko Colin
Quinn you know Patrese r.i.p you know I
mean Bobby Kelly yeah dead people dead
people dead s yeah so it's like I got a
congeal the New York scene and I have
and I'll do I just need to get some I
need to get a bunch of things set before
I could kind of do it but I need to
bring that back because right now it's
just the Comedy Cellar is the greatest
comedy club in the world yeah and I
don't say that as a knock to the store
I'm just saying that's a great that's
all I know that's all I know so and it's
in it's so powerful that the the comics
can kind of I don't want say leech on it
but it can prop us up the comics in LA
took the store from the doldrums of
comedy to the place to be talking about
on your podcast etc it's like I need to
do that with New York on again I need to
redefine what New York comedy is or like
bring back the definition of it and
because like organic it really
everything that hears have an organic I
mean otter swimmer I got a text from
Rogan what RDM from him one night was a
Katie want to be on the podcast and I
felt like I just got another tonight
show you know well it was he tried out
for The Tonight Show seven times you
know and never could get on you know
it's a shame it's one would have killed
yeah you would kill because the people
that watched The Tonight Show are those
people you were speaking about right
oh those my dying to have somebody come
on in there and inter
and that's how stupid these people are
that book these shows is they're still
the people that are watching The Tonight
Show are the the exact people that The
Tonight Show often makes fun of yeah how
[ __ ] dumb can you and they're so
loving most of them that they continue
to try and be supportive they clean up
in it yeah yeah they put up with it
they're like they don't know better but
that's the other thing they like people
on the coast don't realize is it like
you can call it rural but like rural
America has the attitude of they don't
know better right we think that like and
I wasn't guilty of this back in the day
before I kind of really started
traveling a country we think that like
order too stupid to even know to or make
fun of them
in rural America is like let's say it
don't know any better it's they don't
know any better they don't know that
literally they haven't been home in a
few years that's what they think you
know it's sad nobody's cooked for him in
a while
you know if they nobody cares about oh
yeah we're both they're all in lawsuits
yes yeah a hundred percent agree you
saying that makes all those people feel
like defended and you're not you're
saying in a way we're like Pecos well
people laugh too right because your salt
you're all in lawsuits
that's a funny line yeah to make fun of
somebody who thinks that they're living
the life and it's like you haven't seen
a tree in a week yeah you have a walk on
grass yeah I didn't know about grass
yeah I didn't know about graphs yeah
that's why I was like 10 crabgrass is
tricky but the other but they got good
grass out there still just with grass
grass yeah I'm working on it know if
you're doing grass grass you're doing
good okay crabgrass is like I don't even
know a rope yeah it's a grass and rope
kind of mixed together it's bad but I
mean it's useful like you're trying to
make something but yeah it's interesting
that's kind of like that they're waiting
for my even sales stage right now it's
like these people don't know any better
they're third fourth fifth generation
fancy people and they just don't even
their grandfather's used to at least
know somebody or be from where you were
from or have spent time there
they don't even know anybody from there
now how much do they just think it's
okay just to judge them what what is
your culture like what is New York food
it's not even from New York it's Pizza
right
it's
from the places that you're making fun
of yeah right like it's probably from a
recipe from Detroit or a recipe from
Cleveland Italy yeah
it's not from America yeah but it's like
what I'm trying to say is like the
people that are from the homeland they
have things that have existed there for
hundreds of years
yeah right you live in a city you are
living in a very inorganic environment
like a weird
it is weird I even find myself in this
I'm born and raised in Manhattan New
York disease weird really weird what
were your parents were they from their
from their mom is born raised in
Scotland really she had to put trees
outside the window of our apartment
because she missed seeing green [ __ ]
damn I never understood it there's I'm
painting the window green at one point
now we've been smart yeah she's gotta
show oh yeah dude Scottish people are
wild wild why what happened - they're
still there
yeah they're there what's happening to
them their graves chilling I think
they're like to fight Oh Scottish people
or everything dude yeah they're like
yeah no emotion about anything oh dude
it's cool yeah yeah all that all of that
there's so much going on so what's going
on yeah they're the rural people of the
UK are they really yeah I love them man
yeah there's a guy who sends me snaps of
him doing cocaine from Scotland all its
own that's what's up I guess we got cook
all the time and then they honestly just
stopped like abruptly so I hope that guy
honestly is doing okay it could be a
[ __ ] yeah Jodie I think was the guy's
name and I hope he's doing all right
because they suddenly [ __ ] sake of me
was doing a lot like a lot it took some
of the snaps were long Oh
so um what else what other questions
yeah that was just one question yeah
that's just one we got another Andrew
what's up Brent from Fairbanks Alaska
I've been ferrying what are some of the
weirdest places you've toured to maybe
some interesting stories about little
towns or something also was Fairbanks
Alaska one of them gang gang gang bro I
Fairbanks have you yeah obvious witness
protection guy right there yeah
sunglasses in Alaska that is [ __ ] WPP
all over it witness have you been
somewhere like that somewhere rural I
went to I went to Fairbanks did you yeah
yeah yeah it sucked did it it sucked
what was it it was it his why it sucked
were you hunting chicks you go hunting
chicks when you go what are you doing I
had it I brought a girl with me but it
sucked because everything that I wanted
out of Alaska wasn't really there it was
just another city it just happen to be
cold as [ __ ] right like I wanted you
know to Yukon or whatever that [ __ ] is I
want to see the Bears the gold rolling
down the hill all of it yeah I was
excited salmon jumping she'll be hurt
while you're walking on the street whoa
it's a sec fresh right out there yeah I
didn't see the same as drinking [ __ ]
fresh water that's what they do yeah and
they didn't have it none of it oh dude
no that's not true
maybe it is I guess fish die of thirst
when they're out of that's really what
kills them yeah but the good ones
[ __ ] go hard do the Clint Eastwood's
of fish they're out there for a day or
two they could not even wobbling just
having a [ __ ] fly yeah dude Fairbanks
itches
it was but he knows it he understands
what this we went on like a hike it was
it was okay but it could have been any
other like place and when you go that
far it's like if you go to Dubai you
need to see some Dubai [ __ ] right you
can't just see you know Sam you want to
do the Iditarod you learned up more of
an experience so you probably should
have done so yeah so yeah so maybe you
could have done a little more and maybe
there it just could have been a
different experience I tried I tried we
tried to do a pet reindeer oh wow yeah
and then eight reindeer right after that
was pretty gnarly
oh yeah yeah that's good yeah I've had
pony I've never had reindeer before
house pony let me think again ponies
just horse right yeah if you want to
look I don't look at it like that but
female horse is that what a pony is no
it's just small horse it's kind of you
know been through
a lot and it tastes the weird texturally
and in your mouth it tastes like kind of
like a beef that people kind of forgot
about right in your brain it tastes like
kind of like a kid's birthday party a
little bit ooh it has that kind of like
mental taste of what should a pony be
doing you know doing rides at the park
or whatever you know or something like
that
what else do we have I'm getting over
bronchitis fear what's up gang gang
Andrew Andrew I saw the Jew from New
York
Theo and me we're from the south and the
clip you used was from the comedies on
is Charlotte talking about our bathrooms
Andrew talk about some of your
observations about the south since
you're from New York
classic north-south rivalry mix up guys
gang gang peanut like Civil War - dude
let's go everybody had a funny joke
about if they ran it back then the north
will be [ __ ] you think well just cuz
you guys have guns like we gave them all
up yeah I've thought about that a lot
man I think sometimes about the
direction that it like if America's
headed I think about what state
government be better at this point
because some you know states are so
different and it's like you're just
arguing about two perspectives that
other people can't see that was the idea
initially was it yeah like that exact
idea the initial idea was hey dude I
live in Maine it takes me six months to
get to Virginia yeah why should my laws
affect you or your laws affect me why
don't we like have some basic [ __ ] that
we all agree on and then I'll just do my
main thing and you do your virginity
yeah which I guess is what they do have
it's a little bit more like I guess
faded right now but yeah you just you
invented America without even knowing oh
wow dude I was always a really poignant
organic thought well thanks man
yeah you recognized you recognized a
problem yeah that was really good to
just come up with that man that's like
Alexander Hamilton [ __ ] dude hell yeah
bro Alexander Hamilton Bell bro a
phonebook writer
how about this though yeah what if I
thought about this like what if somebody
made an app that told you where
companies put their dollars politically
so
that then you knew which companies you
wanted to support what if I told you
that they put them equally on both sides
is that true no but most of them will
play both sides
yeah you just whoever wins I gotta sell
coca-cola right so I got you yeah me
they're not trying to win the election
they're just trying to win the
politician right so they could keep
doing their you know [ __ ] [ __ ] right I
mean it's a good transparency is good I
like down with my homework then I
thought it would be yeah then there's
more transparency then it's like okay
then you can then you could actually
affect these these cuz then companies
might say okay I don't want to do any to
anybody because I don't want to affect
my sales right because then you would
affect their bottom line yeah I'm like
well Mike because then it would take the
big money out of politics cuz otherwise
a company saying okay right now I'm
willing to lose half of my clientele by
supporting a certain political party or
political affiliation but the tricky
thing is like both sides sorry we're not
addressing your question but we'll get
there but like the tricky things both
sides have something that can be morally
reprehensible yeah to a group
oh so so like if we knew where let's say
dr. pepper was giving that money so dr.
pepper was like I gave you know a
million you know dr. pepper you gave a
million dollars to these problems I'm
gonna drink yeah tab or something
exactly right but they also gave a
million dollars to the Dems right so the
Dems are gonna say how could you give a
million dollars to these people who want
to stop a woman's right to choose right
and dr. pepper was like I just want to
sell Cola yeah I don't they just let me
sell Cola better
it's not about abortion right but
they're gonna bike no you don't believe
in abortion dr. pepper yeah you're not
an abortion doctor so like so so and
then if they give the money so he's
every fine I give them my Democrats now
you got other Republicans like you want
to kill baby dr. pepper you want to kill
him I'll tell her up to two years old
the latest ruling a herd you can kill
him till the ruptals not stood yeah
that's the year after pill [ __ ] is going
on when is it in when is it in seven
year after pill oh well behaved on a
plane
break out a couple of those how old's
the kid doing a lot of crying 16 months
yeah so maybe that isn't me yeah I think
I don't know enough in that in that in
the larger landscape politically didn't
know but yeah we just seem to me like
then that way companies wouldn't you
know it would just start to affect like
even like in Hollywood like so you know
celebrities they wouldn't all be like
okay well let's do this or let's do that
or just telling people how to vote or
whatever you know [ __ ]
yeah you see through Peas you've been in
the other side yeah so like it's all
everybody's full of [ __ ] they're just
you know helping their bottom line or
they're trying to like get another job
acting like most of these actresses and
actors that like come out politically
super hard they just want the distro
survive yeah it's the next role I know
if I say this [ __ ] then I'm gonna look
woke and then this director is gonna
hire me because you want to hire someone
wrote it's all hustle nothing give a
[ __ ] yeah I promise you none of them
good it's like it's like the reason I
was all advertising it's all advertisers
like the art Kelly [ __ ] is coming out
again now cuz he's broke
so he can't pay people off oh wow yeah
it's like that's how stressful that must
have been though just juggling all
pedophilia stuff you know just bossing
around the [ __ ] warming the urine
kind of stantly embossing it around you
know like the produce new year oh I bet
you did he seems like a guy that likes
an eight year nice aged Jared oh yeah
dark isn't it yeah but it is wouldn't it
it's funny though it is funny dude yeah
it's uh yeah I just want to be free also
to say what I want to say like last time
let's say he's Joey Diaz had a stage a
joke added a bunch of racial slurs in it
right ones that we would all not even
probably say on this podcast except you
because you work with a lot of black
people you might be willing to draw I
don't do the n-word huh I don't do the I
know I don't do it did unless you do
ah this joke I seen I quit doing it
probably about four years ago when
everybody else did really yeah you got
off I mean I was like like how you quit
porn after this train is going nowhere
this is one of my favorite videos ever
buy the [ __ ] the the Jewish queen of
comedy right here miss Joan Rivers all
right P getting booked let me tell you
everybody just relax everybody is either
a [ __ ] a [ __ ] a cake a [ __ ] a fairy a
myth
everybody stop beetle are we all just
calm down
maybe we should be thankful for you be
thankful that we're all living in
America and stuck everybody getting so
gay
and this goes to the Indians both doc
and fit she included both of them
feather at the end shot off feather
shout out from who there's not even that
many off there really aren't there ain't
no they don't care if you care I don't
even know yeah I mean it is I don't know
I really don't know but yeah I mean
casinos I do you feel like that things
are better off than the media makes them
seem nervous yeah dude that's dislike
like I've asked you all the questions
that like I have questions too and
you're like how the [ __ ] do you still
have these questions no no I'm not it's
okay it's good I'm not gonna your
question I'm saying like I could I
assume ur asking me this question
because you already feel away about it
you already feel like yeah but I get
over react oh yeah I'm not knocking your
question I'm agreeing with your
sentiment that I'm assuming you have
yeah right so like the justice Millette
situation is a perfect example it's like
one that we found out it was fake right
people went but things like this happen
every day
no they don't that's what I say yeah and
people are literally tweeting they're
like there are lynchings every day where
yeah
somebody told me that is they're still
slaves in South Carolina someone tore oh
look are you [ __ ] crazy possibly only
because yeah people maybe somebody
that's hard-of-hearing and his [ __ ]
committed to their job I mean but
nobody's just like signing up anymore
like what's emancipation name I don't
know what that I mean it really chose
the biggest word to say you're really
they're not gonna know what this means
we can nation they just kept using
bigger and bigger words that's so true
dude that's a tricky move it is a tricky
move that was Lincoln's deal he's like
alright well just use some words a
little bit big we can kind of play both
sides of the net here with the wording
like Ruth you dude like the world and of
course everybody will think ours two
white guys saying there's no no but like
the world is what only so I always speak
up for a black I was I
I know that in my heart I don't want
things to be fair you know yeah and I
know I've always wanted that I mean I've
always you know like I believe more in
green privilege these days that I do in
white privilege what's that mean you
know just money like I don't think Jaden
Smith has a tough time finding [ __ ]
work a thousand orders saying like that
kid ain't waking up worrying about
[ __ ] work
absolutely none out Rollins is on here
talking about how like it's just you
know we're past the time of excuses you
know yes we're fortunately we are and I
think a lot of people recognize you know
that black people had it did not
certainly did not get any Head Start at
all no you know and we're set back for
sure yeah and that you know you still
have to deal with a lot of those things
but it also the excuse culture of people
just it just enables you yeah and
there's people break there's like and
and there's just people bringing down a
lot like people are over like the bottom
feeders who are just trying to bring
down their culture and I think even in
the black community is starting to see
them be like a weed them out yeah out
here like if you're still using these
old excuses like you're not helping us
because no yeah people want to move
forward yeah it's like who are you
hiring like all those people are making
those excuses are you hiring anybody
yeah are you putting money in his pocket
you doing anything all you're doing is
playing off a feels fear yeah
ah so you're no different than a
politician yeah that you might hate and
ownership do when you talk about
ownership you want to talk about still
owning the only people that still owns
anyone these days is networks and yeah
you know and owns like the like lots of
people like that's crazy
like my buddy told me he was being sued
for a picture of his face yeah like
someone took a picture of his face and
he used it on something and they're like
oh that's my picture it's like that's my
face yeah I think are you [ __ ] nuts I
drew that picture literally yeah like
you just hit a button yeah this is mine
a little washer picture every night
every every night yeah that's true yeah
every other night but yeah I think you
make a man you said you said something
really what was it just right before I
want to address it wow really good Oh
use culture no privilege oh you know the
excuse thing is really interesting it's
like because you know what it's like
it's like let's say you have lung cancer
right and you go to the doctor right and
the doctor goes okay you got lung cancer
and you're like in the doctor says okay
this
what we're gonna do we're gonna get you
on these antibiotics and you're gonna
stop smoking you're gonna do all these
that's exactly my whole week dude I'm on
CPAC right now and I'm on my fourth day
and they're smoking
boom right now Jesus dude you're like a
damn soothsayer god damn so what if what
if the the patient was like well while
we talk about what gave me lung cancer
and you're the doctor like no no I'm
trying to cure you of lung cancer I'm
trying to make your lungs better but the
patient kept going no no the cigarettes
yeah
why didn't why were you forcing me to
smoke cigarettes right and it's like
okay we can talk about us all you want
but if you want to not have cancer yeah
this is what you got to do right and
it's not talking about the cigarette
yeah that literally does nothing to stop
cancer yeah you had a certain point we
all we just you know and I guess it is
easier to say for a white perspective
but I don't know when you come from a
poor perspective it just seems like I
don't know I always felt like rich
people thought it felt like poor white
people were like a pariah to them I
don't know what a pariah means but yeah
it was like I'm not [ __ ] with that
dude that guy's gonna [ __ ] my money up
there's this idea that like all white
people are the same and to non-whites
they see us like that yeah but there is
a upper class of whites that wants
nothing to do with any of us in the gym
right now and I've operate in those
circles and it is very clear yeah it is
like that that's that 1% [ __ ] that
exists that's a dark arts dude it is
that's people doing really yeah drinking
each other's blood doing stuff on the
internet what was that guy's question
again was he different oh yeah different
than ourselves look I love I'll be
honest with you I love I love the South
man and I definitely came from that like
bigoted New York thing like I didn't
even like country music without
listening to it that's stupid [ __ ]
people say Oh local music sub country
whatever then I started listening a
country and it is country music is like
the male country females to violence but
me but male yeah Shania Twain stomp
stomp
dude Dixie Chicks poisoning they're
poisoning ya there dude every yeah
this is who do you think cut off Gary
Sinise's legs for that movie Carrie
Underwood probably is that true
there's all kinda [ __ ] out there yes
Gary god bless him but point is like did
country music for me it's like very
Buddhist it's just like except what you
have yeah I like my dog I like a beer I
like a nice day yeah like my car it's
not even that nice it's just a truck but
I like it
hey I love the simple thing I love my
wife I don't let its literal Buddhism
every song never about anything fancy
yeah whatever I love my porch yeah I
love sitting oh I love a beautiful nice
beer on my pour that is so simple how
could you hate it I don't understand how
you could hate it I don't know we'll do
this in a country maybe Oh yes'm no I
love confuse your guys let me see Alan
Jackson
I like lee Brice I like um I don't mind
Alan Jackson actually that's like old
school yeah but I grew up on like Garth
Brooks I grew up being erect and [ __ ]
you know dancing to that [ __ ] I would
even get her right during the ones that
I won't even slow songs and that was a
that's when I knew I was different its
power Garth you know it was like damn
dude yeah yeah this is [ __ ] a lot you
know Chris Stapleton is the best out
right now Chris Stapleton he's the guy
I'm not like super yeah I'm like hacky
like country music I like like Rascal
Flatts yeah good he performed at the
Grammys like last year but he used to
like produce like air church and some of
the big names you already know he's
doing a solo [ __ ] he's he's the real
deal
he's the guy yeah yeah he was on Joe
Rogan he had a really need an interview
on there um yeah I'm trying to think who
else all like uh you know I like Lady
Antebellum um I like I mean I just like
listen to country music I guess I don't
even know a lot of who some of the new
artists are but I listen to country
music in my car all the time yeah that's
good
yeah but that's interesting that it's
like Buddhism what other questions do we
have in here guys that's pretty much it
the other ones were like asking about is
his new special he's got coming up or
when's he gonna release especially told
us that and then something about
independent content and which I feel
like this was the sole oh yeah we've
talked about that yeah it's definitely
interesting man you know it's yeah it's
like weird like I feel like I had like
I don't know if I have fears or anything
it's just interesting to get validation
from a different perspective from a
different city and someone who struggled
in that it within that industry and then
to have also found their own footing and
then industry in inspiring other people
I see you doing it yeah maybe it's just
the gram but like when I see you on the
gram and I see you selling out shows and
I see the podcast blown up like for me i
don't know like for me that's all the
validation I need you don't I mean
actually all the validation I need is
just creating but the anything is extra
so in my mind I'm like yo you're living
a dream yeah like literally that's how I
feel but so yeah but that's just me
maybe there's other things that you want
maybe I know you really want to give
back and maybe you'll really feel like
once you give back that you're doing
yeah maybe I'll feel better then you
know yeah there is something that I just
don't feel okay sometimes I don't feel
like we're doing enough like that's a
survivor's guilt or something like that
yeah it's like you've been in that dark
ass place and you're like if I could
only help more people yeah I always feel
like we should be doing you know more
doing something else or doing I don't
know why it's so funny I was thinking
about that yesterday I was like you know
when will I just kind of like be like
okay what we're doing right now is is it
hard for you to accept success um I
don't know like when you make what do
you think net yeah yeah yeah yeah I
could see that oh he's got this consus
fear it'll go away for some reason and
that's like I think I just don't trust
this industry so much and this you know
I had this fear of it or something
you're outside of them now yeah now it's
your your own people and that was what
it is and like if it goes away which I
don't believe it will because your
connection is intimate with these people
yeah they really love you cuz yeah we
have a lot of good people that come out
you know and a lot of people that are
yeah just regular people that just want
to be they just feel connected to you
man you create a community it's like
that's really well I mean that's another
level of things who you talk about that
too but like I don't know just seeing
that kind of intimate even if it goes
away let's say it goes away you've built
it from zero
yeah you've been here before there's no
fear
because you know how to build it again
right like Elon Musk is like yeah I've
lost a billion dollars before but it's
okay and it's not because he's a
billionaire it's because he's built it
already
like you know you're in the ecosystem
bro yeah
like there's a reason I want to do this
I wanted to do this podcast Rhys you're
in it yeah no I like I was like oh this
is this is gonna be dope man you're in
it you're in the [ __ ] eCos maybe you
don't even realize that you're in it
maybe that's it maybe something like
that and sometimes is easier for other
people to have outside perspective but I
guess I feel like I start to feel like
well if I'm given the opportunity to
have success then I have to also have
you know the opportunity like at the
same time I need to be able to I guess
just do more stuff with it you know you
weren't given the opportunity took it
right you don't get handed power you
take power yeah
physically you take it now that could be
by building the studio getting people
who believe in you and building a team
and coming at three times a week to
record these episodes sacrificing your
friendships girlfriends family but you
take it and then people who are worthy
of having power the last thing they take
is power right this a real king who
takes power all he does after that is
give mmm how do I protect my people how
do I ignore him I do how do I take care
of my people and then he has some bratty
son who [ __ ] the whole thing up
yeah but Jionni that might be Johnny bro
Chloe has a journal that says power this
is why a for gold man this is wild and
he was a c-section baby were you Oh
perfect but I would be perfect but but
yeah so you're in that stage you're like
oh [ __ ] I finally have some like I
finally have some power power is a loose
term but like I finally have some powers
like how can I give back to these people
and I see you do the thing with the
single moms Yeah right it's like I have
to do some cool stuff and we want to do
more of it yeah again you will yeah yeah
we will yes some of it's just this weird
him
patience that I feel like we have to
figure it all out an hour there's not
enough that like you I think what you're
doing is like is what smart people do is
like they create goals that they can't
achieve because they realize how
important a goal is for themselves like
Whitney does this and she's so smart I
don't think she realized she does it but
like she needs something to do yeah yeah
I've seen her Instagram story yes I've
seen everything she does I mean never
met anybody's like patent horse's
[ __ ] putting on makeup going to the
[ __ ] dance going to this Cinderella
midnight ball midnight snack [ __ ] I
don't even know it's going on anymore
and it's just still love me after that
so but but yeah why is it it's like
nothing you have the nice pool we saw
the [ __ ] pool don't pretend like it's
not yours she never says I'm in my pools
he's like oh I'm in this the pool has a
little island on the edge dude I'm from
one end of her pool you can almost see
Russia but it's like she's what she did
is just created a goal that can never be
accomplished which is saving the animals
right all right yeah so it's like you'll
never be able to save all the animals
but at least you have something to do
until you're dead yeah that's a good
point she tried to say that one hot
giraffe and that was a big dude that was
a bolder than the fire Malibu if anybody
should have seen it coming yeah stupid
giraffe like tell the other animals beat
it buddy can't walk over that gate like
giraffe you gotta let the Lord work
sometimes Whitney you know so helping
people is your help and animals yeah and
you're like she's I gotta keep on doing
more of it and you will but no amount of
it will satisfy you right like you'll
always feel like there should be more
and maybe you eventually maybe you get
to oh like a really cool place where you
just love the helping not the amount
right right so it doesn't matter how
many oh yeah video gets it doesn't
matter how much money you get for the
special the joy was to help the act of
helping if it comes like that joke the
two seconds or three seconds in the joke
where you're in a different world is
every time you're helping you're in the
different world and it's like you know
to help I helped one person this month
how [ __ ] awesome and fun was that
yeah not only health one person yeah
yeah it's funny man I think yeah I think
I'd love to be able to fine-tune me
feeling good about just my own life more
over time you know seems like you're
doing it like seems like there's a lot
of growth for you in the last maybe
decade yeah I think oh yeah there
definitely has been I feel like you know
I mean I'm definitely you know I yeah I
think so
and it's you know going to these shows
and seeing people that are just coming
out and having a good time and like you
know a lot Mattias is very loving people
that come out like because you give that
yeah yeah do that yeah
you give bro you give that's rare your
comedian yeah usually we take we're
empty Phil laughs Phil Phil Phil Phil
Phil Phil Phil Phil Phil Phil you yeah I
want to you get filled through giving
it's like some Burning Man [ __ ] you
should come to Burning Man with me
really
I learned extra Burning Man yeah yeah
yeah when the last few years yeah we
should do a show there do list no that's
one of the things I want to give the
whole thing there is about giving
radical gifting how much drugs you have
to do to do it you know what I think
this year I'm not gonna do any wow I'm
not a big drug guy yeah and I think that
like I might take adderall just to stay
awake oh yeah
cuz it's like you don't really sleep
that well you're in the [ __ ] desert
and arvy the whole thing but like I
learned from there like the the value of
giving like how fulfilling that [ __ ] can
be like yeah really help just just
giving someone something yeah how
[ __ ] good that can make you feel oh
yeah it's like I come from New York
which is a taker City it's like how can
i [ __ ] you over how can i swindle you
how can i get you in a second i
swindlers list Manhattan Manhattan New
York bro tell me this about in New York
let's be honest Alphabet City the only
place you can even get you can't even
get mugged in [ __ ] New York anymore
how sad is that bro I know you can't
even get [ __ ] stabbed unless you
[ __ ] you know fall into a silverware
dealer down in Alphabet City yeah that's
all that's the only way so everything
else is so [ __ ] expensive it's so
it's so crazy you got to go far to be in
trouble
yeah you got to go really far and that's
change
bang armored when I first went there you
know 15 20 years ago I ended up in a cab
and a threesome with [ __ ] some of the
guys from O'Town know we had which one
Oh
Audra Blackmore who knows he looked
black there was a black guy from ogloc
dark who knows yeah yeah I like a girl
with liquid dreams no [ __ ] bro my uh
yeah camera what it was
any other questions with Janet Jackson's
thighs Jackson style juveniles there
come to LA or you gonna stay in New York
yeah yeah let's [ __ ] tell it tell it
make a big announcement yeah I'm staying
in New York no I'm uh I'm here just cuz
I'm doing shows and I want to connect
with everybody out here I felt like
something really bubbling out here
especially in the podcast world and like
even in the stand-up world I just want
that you feel pretty welcomed by
everybody I haven't really even been I
haven't done shows really you know I've
been running around too but uh in in the
podcast absolutely man everybody's been
cool and I'm excited to do the shows you
know I got to were taping this on
Wednesday so I got to tomorrow nice but
um but yeah man it was just like there
was something happening here I just want
to like feel it it was exciting
yeah and I just want to like just feel
it but I'm gonna go wherever the career
is for me and right now the career is
everything I'm creating is in New York
you know I live in New York and you know
the podcast I'm doing everything in New
York but uh I'm not locked to a certain
place but I don't have any plans to come
I just like I just actually liked what
you guys were doing out here man
I was drawn to it and I needed two
[ __ ] I just needed to go and just
feel it
think of the think it was probably
inspirational yeah I think that was it
for me it was just like yeah this is I
need a little yeah where do you go when
you need to be inspired or you need it
will give me energy
it gave you energy coming out here like
seeing the studio gives me energy
right just kind of seeing what happens
see what's going on see fighter in the
kid I remember I went on fighter in the
kid and that's when I first started
meeting some of those you know different
podcast people and I yeah and then you
know I think make just email me blah
about because I'd talk to my podcast
about needing a producer well we had I'd
done a little for allegedly when I was
oh yeah that's right before I got laid
out of a previous podcast yeah and uh
and it had tons of celebrity guests
somebody just didn't pick up any
viewership why do you think that was
I don't know and we were on Wendy woods
were on page six all the time like we
had so much press but I think it just
didn't have any it didn't have any
substance at the end yeah I could never
say what I wanted to say whether it was
good or bad you couldn't be you right
and sometimes I still have gotten a
little scared over the past months to be
me but now I think I'm getting a little
bit back more comfortable to it some of
just an adjustment period things like
just getting so busy like yeah just not
knowing what to do and just being like
you know like I don't like being
sometimes out of my comfort zone even if
that's a even if it's a good place that
I'm in right it's still out of your
comfort zone yeah you know like it
doesn't resonate with me any differently
whether it's a scary place or a good
place it's still out of my comfort zone
and so for me it just takes some
acclamation a lot of times you know yeah
there's a and also just success can be
something that's scary because yes
especially if you never you know you
always look you know you always had a
chip on your shoulder against that you
know like because they you know like oh
I can't have that you know like I don't
that's not for me that's for other
people it's like it gave you that
underdog thing you know yeah but that's
what people root for man but then when
that's gone what's your motivation we're
normal aging but also you don't want
people to think you don't wanna become
the thing that you hate yeah yeah like
50 cent is looking for people to beef
with every day because he knows that's
the motor right or like Bernard Hopkins
on off your boxing fan but like he's
from Philadelphia a Philly an execution
right so like he needs to be the villain
in the in the card and when we were
rooting for him it just didn't work he
didn't know how to sell it he didn't
know how to be the what is it in
wrestling but the heel no the heels the
baddest babyface is that the good guy to
face the face right yeah so it was like
he just knew how to only be the heel and
and yeah I guess I grew from that
Despicable Me exactly yeah yeah yeah man
it's it's a weird thing man but it seems
like you're doing I don't know man seems
like you're doing maybe better than you
give
so credit for yeah seems like the people
around you keep telling you that but
you're not realizing it but then not
realizing it might be your motivation so
yeah maybe it's good to have a little
skepticism yeah I'll take all the
skepticism I can get I think man you
know I'm pretty skeptical of me bro oh
you know I think so anyway Drive you you
know yeah I think it must man you know
that's a thing sometimes I don't exactly
know what drives me really you know in
some ways or maybe I do I don't know you
know I don't really know to be fully
honest with you man maybe you do know
but it's excited F initely feel excited
I definitely yeah it's it's definitely
been totally different just having
people come out after like 15 years into
in shows and people finally come out
it's just you know it's different and my
thing is I've just been like I want
everything to be okay it's like when
somebody comes over to your house yeah
when the cops are coming over you hear
they're coming you want to [ __ ] clean
up yeah it's like that's kind of how I
feel like people are coming over you
know let's [ __ ] make sure all like
the [ __ ] candles are lit yeah it's
like you don't want to try new material
it's like no I want to kill for these
guys I want to justify them showing me
love when no one else ever did yeah
let's show them yeah I want to make them
feel good but at the same time like
they'll ride with you even during the
growth yeah and that's what a lot of
them say you know and so I think I think
some of it will be you know get more
settled in and you know and start to
take you know larger confidence and some
of the other maybe mm moves we might
make to expand and do different things
and employ friends and work with friends
and you know and just maybe have more
confidence and and what we've already
created you know I think that's okay
that's why you're here today to to hear
this you know to get it from some of
them just you know that I was inspired
to like talk to and then everybody's
excited about and um you know yeah you
seem definitely have a little bit more
that reverb of kind of like work
confidence you know that I don't know if
it eludes me but just you know I feel
like sometimes I've been different in
other people's waters and you know
there's still this thing and I'm not
allowed in there they don't want me in
there so you know that makes perfect we
all feel that yeah that like I'm not
good enough you really need to come to
Burning Man yeah there's this principle
in Burning Man it's radical
inclusion and it's a weird thing that
happens like when you're included
everywhere no matter what no matter how
you dressed about how you look
no matter anything for the first day
it's a little weird second day it's a
little weird and then the third day this
weird things happen this weird thing
happens where like that voice in your
head that says I'm not good enough it
starts to get real quiet because you're
included in every conversation you could
walk up to anybody and you start talking
and the vedic hey man well how was your
day and when that [ __ ] happens that's
a drug yeah and then you start
connecting with people in this real deep
way because you're not constantly trying
to present an image that you think
people will oh yeah so you could
probably get some really exhale then
you're like oh this [ __ ] suit of
armor that I've been hold hold on what
like I set this over here in the dirt
yeah you know that's interesting man
yeah pull up man come through I like
that man I'll have to I gotta come to
New York City too man any time I got you
yeah and your soul thank you so much my
brother thank you so much for having me
this was great
gang man
[Music]
but when I reach that round I'll share
this piece of mind I can feel it thought
it's gonna take
little town for me to sell that parking
brake and let myself
[Music]